What? Nothing wrong with me.
3 nothing wrong with me.
You do know that none of those are controversial ways to raise boys,
right? I have two sons,
and I'm trying to raise them
with healthy expressions of their masculinity.
And this one, I dress like a tiny gentleman.
But if he ever came to me and said he wanted to wear a dress,
that would be okay, too.
And a good way to make sure their masculinity doesn't turn toxic
is to let them know that it's okay to express themselves.
And even enjoying traditionally feminine things,
activities and dressing is okay.
Things like showing emotion, crying.
Boys should be able to express those things
and not have it hamper their masculinity.
Enjoying certain colors and outfits doesn't hamper their masculinity.
And raising him as his assigned gender at birth
until he tells you otherwise is perfectly fine.
It's what happens if he tells you otherwise that really matters.